you see the sweat or greeting up a
little bit it's going up it looks like
I'm at a game
I think I'm crying actually how my ears
bleeding are we good
[Music]
hey what's going on and happy
Thanksgiving everybody for first we
feast I'm Sean Evans and you're watching
hot ones
it's the show with hot questions and
even hotter wings and today we're joined
by pistons forward Blake Griffin he's a
five-time NBA all-star four-time All Pro
former number one overall draft pick and
slam dunk champion but can he make a
Thanksgiving feast out of the wings of
death we'll find out today Blake welcome
to the show thank you thanks for having
me how are you a spicy food I'm okay I'm
like middle of the road I guess we'll
find out I don't know
[Music]
all right so this first one is the
classic and we'll start at the handle
all right it's good so Thanksgiving it's
one of the biggest sports days of the
year so right off the bat we're diving
into the metrics and early on in your
career it was rare that you'd ever shoot
a three and now you shoot as many as six
per game is that Blake Griffin changing
is that the league changing or a little
bit of both I need a little bit of both
over the years I think you've seen more
especially for power forwards you know
starts to shoot threes I was kind of a
late addition to that really like in the
last couple years I started but that's
just the way everything goes now so I
got to keep up I know that talking
technique is boring but when you decide
to overhaul your stroke game like that
what goes on behind the closed gym doors
it's a lot of frustration and a lot of
like balls basketballs being kicked all
over the gym in frustration it's just a
long process of like completely
rebuilding a shot and trusting that
you're starting from the foundation and
building all the way up but I'm glad I I
glad I put the time in
so throughout pro sports but
particularly in the NBA there's this
spotlight on advanced analytics do you
ever get nerdy about things like player
impact estimate and deferred defensive
rebound chances what are the things that
you keep an eye on I don't really care
about those as much to me now like with
all the advanced analytics there's you
can make an argument for any player or
any stat you want so for me it's about
the eye test I know it's kind of old
school but like you can sit down and
watch a player and know that he's a good
player just by watching him and I don't
really need any statistics to tell me
otherwise you know you're such a
pervasive dunker but this year you're
attempting as many field goals as
anybody and shooting pretty well do you
ever feel typecast as a player do you
ever feel mislabeled a little bit I mean
throughout the years like like you said
early on I I was pretty much in the
paint every every minute of every game
trying to dunk and now as I've slowly
moved out to away from the hoop every
time I go out to warm up there's like
kids watching us warm up and they're
always like dunk it and I just keep
shooting threes they're like no boo boo
like dunk it so you know I feel that
but you know I got it I got to do what I
got to do got to do what's best for
Blake that's right all right so this
next one like out of Texas humble house
this is like mild okay that's nice all
right I can do this maybe for those of
us who have experience neither what's a
bigger thrill putting someone on a
poster in a sold-out arena or getting a
laugh from a small comedy crowd probably
probably the poster on it and then the
sold-out arena but the getting a laugh
in the comedy crowd is for me it was
pretty special and you have some bullet
points on the resume if you look at your
Just for Laughs set you did that roast
battle with Jeffrey Ross he did slam
poetry at the Laugh Factory what is your
proudest comedy achievement so far the
show that I did it just for Laughs
comedy festivals I hosted a show for
five straight nights so five nights in a
row I had to get up and do like open the
show like 10 to 15 minutes and the first
night was the most terrifying thing I've
ever done in my life and then as it went
on I kind of got a little bit more
confidence but it's it's it's scary and
you've put together a pretty amazing set
of tutors including co-creator of the
Chappelle show Neal Brennan what sort of
tools tips tricks has he given you to
help you with the craft he's given me a
lot I mean honestly if there's anybody
who's been like sort of a mentor for me
in the comedy world it's been him I mean
just from punching up jokes here and
there or just giving me stuff to read or
even like technical stuff like you know
come out and move the mic stand and like
you know get comfortable act like you've
been there before so he's definitely
been my comedy coach you all who's the
funniest trash talker in the league who
has the best on court roast game Kevin
Garnett had the best trash talking
because he would like would never look
at you but he would say like crazy stuff
and he would be like you can't you can't
even guard me and you knew he was
talking to you but he would never look
at you so I was like a weird like you
couldn't look back at him and like you
couldn't look away because he it was
just like a very intimidating thing like
he would just be talking and you just
kind of like have to look around or like
try to like get your teammates attention
and like make a conversation but now
he's gone
nobody really nobody holds a candle to
him
all right so this next one smoked onions
from butterfly bakery
[Music]
it's delicious oh it's got a little kick
a little bit no we're good so staying on
the topic of comedy I know that you
shied away from writing about the NBA
early on when you were working on things
but have since developed a write which
you know approach right if you were ever
to do a show where you Lampoon the life
of an NBA player like Mark Wahlberg did
with Hollywood actors in Entourage what
sorts of things would you focus on I
would probably focus on just the
lifestyle like the parts that people
don't really get to see like the bus
rides in the locker room before the game
you always hear when guys retire that's
what they miss the most is like the
camaraderie the conversations and stuff
like that is there anything funny about
being an NBA superstar that no one else
can relate to I think people just
yelling at you all the time and then
feeling like it's okay there's always
somebody in the front row that always
just like it has to say something and so
you're like five feet away from somebody
like this and they're like yelling at
you that you suck and you don't really
say anything you just kind of look at
them and you kind of like go on about
your day and like no other scenario in
life does that happen where you're that
close without at least like a car length
in between right and no other scenario
would somebody like that say that to
somebody who's six foot a six right
right exactly so you buy a ticket you
get a lot of confidence
[Music]
I bet it's just one bite is fine you
know you can commit to it however you
want you know if you want to clean wings
if you're hungry you can clean wings
okay I'm just gonna pace myself for that
smart and maybe go back through if you
have more questions so we have this
running joke with hot ones creator Chris
Schoenberger and his dog Ruggles who
could probably use some discipline he's
an 85-pound maniac do you have any
advice from somebody who once owned one
of the most well trained German
Shepherds on the planet I do I just
moved him out here to Detroit and so for
the last like two months it's been like
kind of a nightmare because he's just
all out of sorts man he's just like he
doesn't know what's going on he's not
used to like all this room and stuff so
I'm probably not the best person to ask
but a lot of love a lot of attention you
know always seems to Trey and Brooke has
kind of an interesting back story can
you talk about how he came into your
life yeah so my house got broken into
like three oh yeah it's got a little
kick to it huh I like three years ago my
house got broken into him and so I was
like talking to somebody about you know
possibly getting a home security dog mmm
here it comes
huh so I like eventually found this guy
who trains basically police dogs dogs
FBI and all that just dogs like a he was
a drug dog he was like a home or home
security dog like everything so he knows
like 40 commands most in German he's
pretty intense and scares people so but
he's also like just the biggest like
softie ever if you actually like get to
know him so he's a very very smart dog
it's pretty it's very impressive
i Blake are you ready to move on oh yeah
sure
[Music]
good eye blink we have a recurring
segment on our show called explain that
Grimm we're doing deep dive on our guest
Instagram poll interesting pictures that
need more context we're doing a little
bit of a curveball on the Thanksgiving
special we're gonna do explain that
poster we've pulled some iconic Blake
Griffin dunk photos and you just say
what you remember about the play the
game that time in your career and we'll
just go from there is that sound good
cool all right laptop please how you
doing so far my man not bad I'm halfway
through I guess and you're hanging in
there yeah I'm all right
Oh Pau Gasol game I remember it after I
dunked this my teammate DeAndre Jordan
came and just shoved me so hard that I
almost fell down
you know after you don't you try that
cool and he just kind of disrupted that
whole thing for me cuz I had to
concentrate I'm not falling over but
that was that was a fun one what makes a
good poster for you is that the height
of the guy that you're dunking on like
what is the notch in the belt I think
yeah I think so I think like the bigger
the guy the better defender better shot
blocker the better the poster so yeah
definitely I guess you know pals of
7-footer still own gotten twice in this
game yeah alright up next this season
again I remember trying to like play
cool afterwards and one of my teammates
was like look at me like running back
down the court look at me yell at me and
I was just like looking at like not act
like this let's stay focused here like
it was a pretty intense game but that
was another fun one do you remember this
one I do I do
that's Timofey Mozgov yeah Timofey that
was a kind of like a breakout game for
me and in a way like I was my rookie
year probably like 12 15 games in the
season and I just kind of remember like
after that dunk like it just never
really slowed down for me like that's
kind of what I like picked up and it's
just like it's just been crazy since
then and I always kind of like go back
to that time that that was like kind of
the dunk
where are we getting on the Scoville
rating here about ten times hotter than
a jalapeno here okay all right so wanna
stay on the topic of dunks can you draw
back the curtain um what it's like to
prepare for a dunk contest you take
pitches work with the team write a bunch
of things down there's a kind of like
comedy where you want all the creative
control oh no I was I was very on my own
for that one the thing that I knew I
wanted to do is was use a car and
originally I wanted to use like a
convertible and like have it be driven
out on the court but my teammates have
like four teammates in it have one toss
it up and like jump over the middle of
it and I wasn't allowed to use a
convertible I had to use like a KIAC so
it was the NBA sponsor and I don't know
if you stood next to a Kia Optima but
it's a big car so I was like alright I
still want to do it but I'll just jump
over the hood and have a teammate out
the sunroof it works but then people
were like oh you didn't jump over a car
jumped over the hood I'm like have you
seen the hood man it's like you know so
I got some heat for it but you know I
that was that was a fun fun dunk contest
do you think that the public has been
desensitized to dunks with YouTube in
the internet you know there was a time
where the big showcase was the dunk
contest and now you can go on YouTube
you can see a million different kinds of
dunks and Jared smacks you right in the
face do you think it's harder to impress
people these days yeah a little bit but
it's also cool because like there's guys
that aren't in the NBA who maybe aren't
even playing overseas who are
unbelievable dunker so you know you get
to see these like dunk highlights all
the time so yeah maybe the dunk contest
is taking a little bit of a hit but
overall in terms of like the the scope
of dunk consumer versus yeah exactly so
it's great for basketball it's great for
the dunk fan but maybe not the dunk
contest
I'm just looking at these like this one
has a caution sign this one is like
Medusa and downs yeah
gets a little real at this one this one
a pair comes there we go
my nose is sweating I'll just wipe my
face with more hot sauce all right yeah
so once read a great comment that you
made where you said sometimes in the
moment when I'm doing a press conference
one of my favorite things is to watch
reporters what amuses you about
observing the sports media I think
sometimes you'll see a guy who's like
maybe you don't see often so like maybe
he's just like a new guy or whatever and
they're just like gearing up for the
question you're after the question like
ready to ask it and my favorite is like
when they get the mic and they're like
and you can tell they forgot their
question and then they just have to ask
you like a softball question you're
looking like you blew it man I was like
you're one time but most the time like
me yeah it's hot that's a good one yeah
most the time I asked pretty good
questions so what's something that the
beat reporters the ESPN's of the world
and they covered the NBA what's
something that they don't focus on
enough and what's something that they
focus on too much
I think the pride oh no if they all talk
if like before they start asking
questions the press comments they're all
like oh like this this and this because
they all ask the same questions just in
different ways I think if I was a
reporter I would just listen to the
first four questions and then have
something totally different
okay all right so this next one is the
bomb beyond insanity all right
[Music]
sometimes he's got a Dively Oh yuck you
can taste the hotness right away that's
uh
[Music]
go for a little more there I'm starting
to sweat so you're one of the athletes
who's truly transcended sports from
everything from stand-up to film to
unpaid internships to Funny or Die so
what I want to do is bounce some of the
Blake Griffin off the court off peas
pop-culture moments and you can just
give me the highlights okay sure what
was the more awkward nude experience
shooting with broad city or with ESPN's
body issue Wow I think his paeans body
issue because I had to hear like a and
wear like a thong basically pretty much
so that was like uncomfortable that
broad city when I was wearing like these
[Music]
I don't like Spanx type things which is
awkward but not as bad as wearing a
thong what rap shout-out are you know
proud of between the following gucci
mane
I ain't Blake Griffin I don't drive
Nokia for 10 mil I can't sign no deal or
Meek Mill I slam dunk in that [ __ ]
Blake Griffin you're home little Meek
Mill came first it was like a long time
ago so I really liked that one but I
like both guys a lot and you know Gucci
incorporating the Kia thing is pretty
it's pretty good do you have a favorite
Blake Griffin named Jack and hip hop
just the ones you said we're great
but what's the more separable experience
doing a live read of sorry we're acting
alongside Whitney Cummings in the female
brain the female brain is awesome I
think you said earlier Neal Brennan and
Whitney both you know co-wrote that and
then we need directed it so perhaps for
now there's a lot of fun and then that
complex got a few weeks ago
Allen Iverson said of MBA style every
night is Halloween and someone who's
graced the cover of GQ what are your
thoughts in the current state of MBA
off-court style um it's pretty exciting
because it's like a it's almost like a
what's you know what's gonna happen next
like who's gonna outdo who or like what
crazy outfit is Russ kind of wear or
whoever now so it's always fun to kind
of see that ha ha ha the next thing you
see the sweat oh my god up a little bit
it's bringing up it looks like I'm at a
game I think I'm crying actually how my
ears bleeding are we good
are you ready to move on yeah sure as
this next one is the XRS Cup squad
[Music]
okay
are you sure my ears aren't waiting dude
I got you oh good all right the second
eye feels like something's coming out of
him
I Blake bull we're almost at the top of
the mountain but before we get there I
want to take it down memory lane to
Oklahoma City a place I can tell has a
special place in your heart if I only
have one afternoon should I visit the
National cowboy and Western Heritage
Museum or climb the Sand Ridge sky trail
yeah I really like the cowboy Museum
this prequel Oklahoma has like a rich
cow town like cowboy history so if
you're into that type of stuff you know
go for it
onion burgers overrated or underrated
underrated very underrated there's a
really good place that mother Tucker
yeah mother Tucker's a good one not
spicy at all just nice and bland what
was the best thing and what was the
worst thing about your dad being your
high school basketball coach the best
thing like I didn't realize it at the
time but like afterwards I was so
thankful because he just really like
pushed me away harder than maybe another
coach would have and he knew exactly how
to you know get the most out of me the
worst thing was like well him being a
coach and also a teacher at the high
school that I went to like he heard
about everything and I got in trouble a
few times so there was no like oh maybe
my parents won't find out about this
because like my dad was three doors down
yeah thanks all right Blake Griffin why
are you using while you have the bottle
this is the last dab we call it the last
dab because it's tradition around here
to put a little extra on the last wing
and today on our third ever Thanksgiving
special we're starting a new tradition
with the turkey leg we will be dabbing
come on in Chris a turkey leg instead of
a wing does this already have stuff on
it nope this one's naked so that's why I
got the bottle out put a little extra
I'm the turkey leg you don't have to if
you don't want to
[Music]
and then dive right in
[Music]
coming at you from all sides here I'm
the Thanksgiving special of hot ones and
what a feast it's been Blake Griffin
from the classic through to bomb and now
a turkey leg with the last dab and as we
close it out I'd just like to say what
I'm thankful for while holding this
turkey leg I'm thankful for my dad fresh
out of surgery and doing well I love you
dad
I want to say thank you to the crew who
all year long has traveled all across
the country popping this set up working
from sunrise to sunset to make this
silly show go and then finally and the
biggest thank-you of all to the fans
who've now rocked with us through seven
seasons in it to the third ever hot ones
Thanksgiving special thank you thank you
for all this what do you thankful for
bleep the milk right there that's it
right now it's a whole well look at you
you legend ten chicken wings up ten
chicken wings down and even a turkey leg
to boot and now there's nothing left to
do but roll out the red carpet for you
my man this camera this camera or this
camera let the people know what you have
going on in your life right now man it's
basketball season so that's all I'm
focused on but got a lot of really cool
stuff going on charity world starting to
work on next year's County by Blake so
that'll be a lot of fun so hopefully you
guys check it out
[Applause]
have a good time feels awesome well it's
good to have you in the seat finally how
are you a spicy food you can't get up a
little bit a little bit I don't I don't
get crazy
I'd like this is gonna be all the
comedic elements that you want that's
gonna happen look at me i'm pasty as
health you know salt and pepper was
about as hard as we went in the house
hey what's going on spice Lords this is
Sean Evans checking in by his lonesome
and you know what that means it's time
for another hot sauce PSA and for two
years we've been working on making the
perfect entry-level sauce something
that's good for everyone number one on
our board and now it is finally here the
classic is our contemporary twist on the
original vinegar-based sauces throughout
American history with chili de arbol
peppers and garlic for that perfect
balance as always people who order the
hot ones monthly subscription box got it
first but now it's available for
everyone heat nice calm heat nice calm
to pick up the classic the classic it's
for the people
[Music]